ce sont des frappes de plus longue
distance
et sa région cette nuit
les Armée de l'Air ukrainienne dit avoir
abattu 4 missiles de croisière et au
moins une quinzaine de drones mais le
gouverneur de la région de denis-pro
pétrole que dans ni pro et la capitale
dit qu'il y a aussi eu des missiles qui
ont atteint leur cible et que ce sont
essentiellement des cibles militaires
bien sûr les autorités ukrainiennes ne
donnent pas plus de détails sur cela ils
disent tout de même que on résultat de
ces frappes pendant la nuit il y a au
moins oui blessés quand ils disent qu'il
y a au moins 8 blessés cela entend oui
civils qui ont été blessés ils se
peuvent que des militaires étaient
blessés aussi mais les Ukrainiens
donnent pas des détails sur cela
essentiellement les régions de ni pro
pour ces profs de longue distance mais
aussi elles aporisa et archives deux
autres grandes villes de l'est de
l'Ukraine ont été frappés pendant la
nuit les sirènes ont retenti sur toute
l'Ukraine mais la capitale qui est n'a
pas été visée
cette fois-ci ce qui contraste avec les
jours précédents on a eu une nuit de 13
la nuit avant-hier mais sinon à qui
avait été ciblé pendant au moins cinq
nuits de suite